right welcome back to the podcast
episode 6 today we have the genius that
is
hendricus the soil Whisperer this is the
guy when it comes to uh understanding
the biology of soil what goes into the
foundation of growing the foods that we
eat he understands it in a very unique
and comprehensive way and so we're
really lucky to have him on today to
talk a little bit about getting back to
basics um in terms of how food is grown
we talk about GMOs we talk about
Monsanto we talk about prop 37 we talk
about um different ways of looking at
your food and give you guys some tips
when you go to the grocery store about
what to look for what to avoid and that
kind of thing um but
talk a little bit about like tapping
into your heart learning to trust your
instincts question authority good food
starts with the foundation the soil and
good decisions and a good life
trajectory starts with looking
inside everything
follows amazing thanks for being with us
today we hope you guys like the show
we're having fun doing this thanks for
the support um
going keep rocking so catch you next
time